yeah what coming to this new blitz game
playing giant from I hope this is
Denmark yes all right so then only
modern benoni and i played this night g3
system quite often recently with
excellent opening results I actually
took this recommendation from the yeah
what's the book called even spy last
Randolph playing d4 I think it's called
playing d for the Indian defenses or
something like that and he's got this
recommendation against the Benoni now
shut up this from Denmark incident
incidentally ok took quite a while for
for Bishop g7 quite sure it's a normal
or the most normal move anyway in the
position quite curious yeah h5 is a
common idea trying to irritate this
night but I don't really mind to go to
h1 I know each one is not the greatest
spot for the night but the rewrote
reroute squares f2 and this is where the
night really wants to be f 2 is a good
square who interesting 95
and I wonder if
this MF form f 494 h3 is there some some
some tactic a lot otherwise this really
doesn't make much sense 9594 h3 and ya
don't really don't really think that
could be a tactic like 94 but don't
really see it working he has named
castle yet and if he needs to play night
age 6 and this was so yeah frankly
speaking nonsense why would you reroute
unite to h6 web doesn't have a squared
give why the complete center so we
actually needs to do something out of
the ordinary here right h6 is so just
very sad
but I really don't think you can
sacrifice here
at least not objectively
yeah the anti-islam playing it after all
the question is some what's best now is
not clear even the [ __ ] if I yourself
a move that needs to be considered you
five so the kind of move that might be
excellent but also gives black a a
square on f5 for the night I rather have
my piece play on f2 8 h 1 is not not
great at the long run so let's use this
piece if he castles then if we castles
here I could play you 5 this yeah this
prevents be 5 or at least makes it more
difficult to play and maybe a f5 coming
it looks very shaky to play at five but
maybe he can do it
interesting five
I don't think I have any any immediate
way to to punish this one idea could be
at 555 but I guess maybe you will castle
first anyway
ok
I don't really see black playing b5 ya
ever with the situation on the King side
now if he castles I play a five and wind
annoyed it just doesn't have a square
and then i'm not sure but maybe i'm even
threatening e5 immediately be five and
94 coming and he cannot castle what does
black supposed to play now if you cannot
castle yeah this one but I thought if
five would be good i hope that this
assessment is correct after taking
taking takes takes Bishop b5 sh6 hanging
and after Knight takes their c5 hanging
and both looks terrible I cannot castle
now the Benoni is an opening that really
doesn't yeah it doesn't give you much
leeway like you can any sort of an acura
CL might might cost the game immediately
yeah I'm trying to keep us King in the
middle so Bishop f1 king of 70 probably
still something something more forceful
not sure king of some how to how to go
about that this night on earth too yeah
maybe I'd like to get it to F war two is
six something like that I know he can
cancel this was so stupid I probably I
didn't have a way to prevent it anyway
hmm ok
there's some how black is back in the
game not quite sure what I did wrong
there
dad I'm not in bad shape but I really
thought that black was in very very very
bad shape I mean like lost or anything
but it doesn't seem to be the case now
at least
and my 2 D 3 i'm not not sure at all
quite quite complicated now
yeah okay that seemed
and the bishop I want to go to c3 with
the special which should should be
helpful
the deep on dangerous
time morning
check
check
check
check check check black 1.8 seconds yeah
wow it was probably very bad play with
me he really shouldn't see move 25 in
this game it's work that get ugly now
I'll get this this this should be really
winning for what yeah the combo GUI is
plus plus two but somewhere here they
need to improve I mean this is probably
not terrible but not the best what's the
best move 93 years the computer mouse
yeah me too what you need to do is you
need to try to prevent 96 and castles
maybe 93 is a good way to to do that
let's check briefly night d 3 for you
then place this move I can take and play
here or something better you
yes this is ok it's just very nice like
this oops i have bishop t4 of course
sorry not f7 and 94 who like this this
looks nice yeah I need to keep it in the
middle of the king probably this is this
is more precise here it's already not so
clear according to the comp amazingly
and this is already a game like and I
can play this it's not great but ok I
can I can take a six-year yeah I saw
that but it looked quite quite weird and
why is this good mission basics I don't
get it if he takes him
I look II 6-yard computer stuff okay I
didn't see that of course maybe on a
very good day you see stuff like that a
tournament game okay guarantee i already
it's it's everything it's it's perfectly
all right now this position for black
amazing yeah interesting thanks for
watching